also breaking tonight a woman is dead  after riding a moped she was riding on  crashed into a pickup truck happened on  Belmont Street not too far from Lake  Mead and Pecos just after six tonight  North Las Vegas Police say the man  driving the moped was also hurt police  officers are looking for the driver of  the pickup who drove away after the  crash and was last seen near Mojave and  Owens they are looking for an older  model white or silver work truck which  may be hard to make out in this  surveillance footage that was sent to us  by the police department if you have any  information please call North Las Vegas  Police